[Music]
you did something interesting I've just
about you played semi-pro baseball when
you were young and you played in Russia
I didn't know there was semi-pro ball in
Russia oh man that is where all of the
greatest baseball players flock to then
they all did it's totally under the
radar but they all shoot to Russia man
so it is absolutely not true man it
makes Italian oh I got that yeah I'm
sure I'm curious like John like who is
do Russians even care about baseball
like what what are Russians watching
baseball do they understand it did you
answer an ad in the back of a magazine
yeah no I mean it was it was you know I
have no idea what polo is like here in
America but I associate it with that
it's rare you know rich Russian mob guys
can take their model girlfriends to go
see some baseball on the on the weekends
do they do they follow the game and no
not at all they have no idea what's
going on the whole time but people go
and so are you playing with other
Russians yeah yeah every team's allowed
one American and that was that was so
you speak Russian not not well man I I
did I I you know when I was playing no I
I sure did so you played on a baseball
team in Russia as I did and all of your
teammates are Russian and you don't
speak Russian that is that is that work
doesn't work well I played catcher and
and and and you know if you know the
catcher is the field general so that's
its its own special brand of panic when
there's a guy rounding second and I'm
just screaming throw home throw home and
you know they have no idea what I'm
talking that's insanity yeah yeah great
experience yeah it was